i would love if this kind of calculation
happened uh like during the making of
the show or
the you know i love it like in um
for example i now know um alex garland
the director of ex machina
and i love it he doesn't seem to be some
not many people seem to do this but i
love it when directors
and people who wrote the story really
think through the technical details
like whether it's knowing like how
things even if it's science fiction
if you were to try to do this how would
you do this like stephen wolfram and his
son
were were collaborating with the movie
arrival
in designing the alien language of how
you communicate with the aliens
like how would you really have a
math-based language that that could span
the alien
and being and the human being
so i i love it when they have that kind
of regular the martian was also big on
that like the book in the movie was all
about like
can we actually is this plausible
can these happen it was all about that
and that can really bring you in
like the sometimes the small details uh
i mean
the guy that wrote the martian book is
another book
that is also filled with those like
things that when you realize that
okay these are grounded in in science
can
just really bring you in yeah right like
there's a book about a colony on
the colony on the moon and he goes about
like all the details that would you know
be required about setting up a colony in
the moon
and like things that he wouldn't think
about like the the fact that
um they would you know it's hard to
bring like
uh air to the moon say so they wouldn't
like how do you make that breathable
that
environment breathable you need to bring
oxygen but like
you you you probably wouldn't be bring
nitrogen so what you do is like instead
of having a
an um and an atmosphere that is a
hundred percent
oxygen you like decrease the pressure so
that you have the same ratio of
oxygen on earth but like lowering the
pressure here
and so like things like water boils at
the lower
temperature so people would would have
coffee and the coffee would be colder
like there was a problem in this uh
environment in the moon so
like and these are like small things in
the book
but i i studied physics so like when i
read this
i that throws me into like
tangents and i start researching that
and it's like
i really like to read books and and
watch movies when
they go to that level of detail uh uh
about science yeah i think interstellar
was one where they also consulted
heavily with with a number of
yeah i think even resulted in a couple
of couple papers about like the black
hole
visualizations and um yeah but there's
there's even more examples of
interesting science around like these
fantasy
we were reading at some point like these
guys that were
trying to figure out if if the tolkien's
middle earth if it was uh round if
it was like a sphere if it was like a
flat
based on the map based on the map and
some of the references in the
in the books and so uh yeah we actually
i think we tweeted about that
yeah we did based on the distance
between the cities you can actually
prove
that that could be like a map of a
sphere or like a spheroid
and and you can actually calculate the
radius of that planet
that's fascinating i mean yeah that's
fascinating but
there's something about like calculating
the number like exactly the calculation
you did for for the battle winterfell is
um
there's something fascinating about that
because it's not like being
that's very mathematical versus like
grounded in physics
and that's really interesting i mean
that's like injecting mathematics
into fantasy there's there's something
um
i see magical about that and and that
for me that's why i think it's also when
you look at
things like like from fermat's less
theorem
like problems that are very kind of
self-contained
and simple to state yeah i think like
that's the same with that paper it's
very easy to understand the boundaries
of the problem you know
um and and that for me that's why those
and that's why math is so appealing and
those like problems are also so
appealing to the general public
it's not that they look simple or that
people think that they're easy to like
solve but i feel that a lot of the times
they are
almost intellectually democratic because
everyone
understands the starting point you know
you look at fermat's last theorem
everyone understands like is th this is
the the universe
of the problem and the same maybe with
that paper everyone understands okay
these are the starting conditions
and um and and yeah that the fact that
it becomes intellectually democrat and i
think that's a huge motivation
for people and that's why so so many
people gravitate towards these like
riemann hypotheses or vermont's last
theorem or that simple paper which is
like just one page
it's very simple and i just talked to
somebody i don't know if you know who he
is
jocko willink who is uh this person
who among many things loves military
tactics
so he would probably either publish
a follow-on paper maybe you guys should
collaborate but he would see the
fundament the basic assumptions that he
started that paper with is flawed
because you know there's like dragons
too right there's like
like you have to integrate tactics
because not it's not
it's not a homogeneous system it's not i
don't take into account the dragons and
like
and he would say tactics fundamentally
change the dynamics of the system
and so like that's what happened
so uh yeah so at least from a scientific
perspective he was right but he never
published so there you go
you